始まるぞ
なんだこのスピード勝負的な動画は
よしいこうぜ
エイジ：10分くらいで撮らないとですね
はじめ：そうだそうだ　終電が無いからな
気合い入れていくぞ
俺のマネしたっしょ？
エイジ：いやしてないっすよ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと
アバンティーズのそらちぃと
ツリメでーすエイジと
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと
アバンティーズのそらちぃと
ツリメとエイジです
というわけで今日はなんと僕
夜なので外でする場所もないと
体育館も借りれない
誰だよ屁コイタ奴
となるとドッヂボールできる家となると
エイジの家しかないというわけで
バレーボールの球を買ってきました
これで実際にドッヂボールを今日はやってみようと思います
早速4人でドッヂボールで遊んでいきたいと思います
頑張っていこう！
やばいやばいやばい
ボタンのこれが取れたからね
犯人だ犯人だ
家の中でドッヂボールってことはな
こっちにも無敵の代物がある
おかしいよ
エイジ：じゃあ僕が守りをします
気を付けッ！礼！
お願いします！！
*美しい*
＼(゜ロ＼)ココハドコ? (／ロ゜)／アタシハダアレ?
今の壁　今の壁セーフ
本気でいけ本気で行け
滅びよバースト！！
滅びろバースト
*悲しげな音楽*
(´;ω;｀)
はじめ：お前ら・・・
はじめ：よくもエイジを
そらちぃ：止めれるもんなら止めてみな
はじめ：来い！
滅びろバーストストリーム
*悲しげな音楽*
そらちぃ：よくもやってくれたな...おい！！
そらちぃ：よくもやってくれたな..おい！っしょしゃｃｄｗび